[Music]
you've been married uh quite a long time
how's it going uh with you in the
bedroom
you're kidding look at this
isn't that what you said yes i did but
it seemed to work for me uh
no
do you like let me ask you this i don't
want to get specific do you like talking
about that stuff i mean i i find that
i'm i
i don't talk about those things often do
you enjoy talking about that not to you
okay
well how about on television let's say
someone else were here asking the
question if somebody comes on and wants
to talk about it it's okay with me okay
you're fine with it it's all right with
me it doesn't bother me i don't like
take my shoe off and dig my toe in the
carpet right i mean people is that what
you're into it sounds like you're into
people sounds like you've got a toe
thing going on people get bashful what
gets me is i don't get people having all
of this internet sex without ever
meeting each other that i don't get so
we didn't grow up explain how that works
yeah well okay please i get it uh
it's the anonymity of it uh you can say
your cronin orion and uh
put on a different mask or something
orion
no i guess what i'm saying is i i i
think you're right there's no
there's no intimacy there
internet sex is not sex are you kidding
me these people say they're having phone
sex and internet sex i'm sorry i'm just
an old country boy from texas you gotta
be together to have sex on the internet
typing stuff up is not having sex i'm
sorry this doesn't qualify andy way in
here because andy
has a ton of internet sex